This video is sponsored by Next Games, creator of AMC's official game The Walking Dead:No Man's Land.
I put a link in the description so you can go download the game for free and it comes with a special offer!
I'll tell you about in a few minutes.
What's up guys welcome back for this video today,
I thought it'd be fun to take a little bit of an apocalyptic twist now if you're to find yourself in a survival
emergency or zombie apocalyptic situation,
One of the most valuable resources you could get your hands on would be clean drinking water you won't last very long without it
so for this video today,
I thought it'd be great to show you how to use resources you already have to make clean drinking water for yourself
So quick update guys. I just stepped outside for a second
I walked over to my fish pond which ironically doesn't have any fish in it
But it does have a massive amount of other kinds of life as you see here. We've got Mosquito larvae
We've got these little worms flopping around all over the place
We've got algae and all kinds of junk and other little parasites that probably will help very much in your quest for survival
But I am going to drink it once we make our filter and sterilize the water
We need a simple way to filter all this garbage out before we sterilize the water and to get started
We're going to be making a simple sand
Charcoal filter
now to get started making our sand charcoal filter of course we're going to need some sand we're getting some charcoal and we're going to
Need some kind of a plastic container like these simple little water bottles
You probably have lying around
Now because sand, clay and rocks have different densities if you put them in a container with water and stir it all up
The rocks will fall to the bottom first followed by the sand and the clay on top
any organic material left behind will float up with a surface where you can skim it off by using these layers of
Separation with one chunk of dirt you can end up with nice small pebbles very fine sand and the clay which we don't actually need
For this experiment. Or you could use something like a strainer and filter out the finer sand that way as well
So now that we've got our fine sand our small pebbles and a small water bottle the only thing left to do is crush up
some charcoal
Now for this experiment. I'm using the same charcoal I used for our black-Powder experiment
We made in the previous video
however
If you don't want to go to the trouble of making your own you can just look around a campfire
For those large chunks of black wood they're charred and snap in half when you press them if your charcoal is done
Right it should just about crumble if you apply any kind of pressure to it
Which is good because the finer we can get our charcoal the better our filter is going to work
now of course my charcoal is just a mixture of small twigs paint sticks and
sawdust
which I like to sawdust because it's already in fine powder form to begin with but whatever material you end up using to make your
Charcoal should be just fine because it all ends up is pretty much the same stuff
The goal is just to make it a very fine powder because the finer your charcoal is the better your filters can work
that's beautiful
Here we are guys we have all of our filter materials prepped and ready for assembly
So let's take our plastic water bottle cut off the bottom and put a little bit of paper towel on the bottom to catch everything
As it falls in now, if you don't have any paper towel or fine cloth
You could use a bit of your shirt
You can use some sock any kind of cloth really that's going to stick down the bottom and hold the charcoal in place
Preventing it from slipping through so now that we have our paper towel in place
We can go ahead and start adding the filter materials fineness to courses so in this case
We're going to start with the very fine charcoal powder and build that up a few inches deep
Followed by as much of the fine sand as we can pack in there, and then a nice top layer of small pebbles
And that's really to protect the system from the water this splashing in and just to go one step further
I took the bottom of the bottle and cut it into a makeshift baffle to stick it on the top and help reduce erosion
As we pour the water in now
This is a very basic style filter and the more material you could add the better it will work and you could also get creative
With some different variations for example you could layer the charcoal and the sand
Charcoal, sand as many times as you want or you can even just cut the water bottle in half, use the top part of it
To form the filter and use the bottom part to form the cup
The time has come to take our scummy pond water and test our filters to keep it work now if you look at the water
Itself this has been sitting out for about 45 minutes
and you can see that already a lot of the material in there has settled down to the bottom and
Relatively filtered itself through gravity we've got organic material and bugs floating at the top
But the water is a lot clearer than it used to be so step number one in filtering your water if you can
Let your water sit out for a few hours. So most of the material can settle down to the bottom first
So I've just made the transfer you can already see that this water is so much cleaner than this water here
There's still little bugs floating around there and a lot of other nasties
But we can now take this water and pour it into our filter and cleanse it even further watch this
So our water filters are charged and is going to take a little bit of time for the water to filter through
So while we're waiting for that let me show you a fun way you can brush up on those crucial survival strategies for surviving that
Inevitable zombie outbreak I put a link down in the description to download The Walking Dead No Man's Land.
It's a free game with a special offer. That's only available right now
now if you're the kind of person that likes playing checkers chess or turn-By-turn
Strategy type games this might be a good choice for you
You actually use the characters you know from the television show The Walking Dead
In the actual Walking Dead Locations like the terminus in the prison when I was doing a road trip down to La with my friend
Mark a few weeks ago. I actually spent six hours straight playing this game, so I made it pretty far
So you take turns moving people around and every time you move then the zombies get a chance to move as well you have to
use a little bit strategy you have to do some tactical maneuvers you have to think your way through it because if you make the
Wrong move all of your hard work can go down the drain the more cleverly you can position your people the better your chances at
Winning it's a lot of fun
And there's some back-end strategy going on as well because not only are you defeating the zombies and rescuing humanity, you also get to play
Around with developing an encampment you start out with and you can choose how to set it up to build up your colony and fortify
It if you're a fan of the TV show The Walking Dead you're going to recognise characters like Daryl Rick
Michonne and Negan which by the way if you download the game right now
You'll get the character Negan for free
It would actually be really cool if they could make a King of Random character.
The game is available on IOS, Android and pretty much any other device
so if you like zombies
And you want to rescue humanity hang out with characters you know and slaughter hordes of the undead?
Go down to the first link of the description download the game for free the offer is only available right now
All right back to the experiment
Alright guys. We are back. We've been running these filters for about 45 minutes now to the point where the cups are actually overflowing
So let's stop for a second and observe the different results between the different filters
So just by looking at the different colors of the water here
It looks like the one on your right is actually the clearest and this is the one that we built in this video
It's got the layer of charcoal on the slot on the stand in the middle of the pebbles on the top and is this pretty
basic Design now look if we screw the cap on
We can actually contain everything inside and just set that off to the side to be used again at another time
You know what else is really crazy is if you look at the top of the filter you can actually see like the little worms
The Larva the bugs like jumping around and floating on top. They don't make it past the rocks though
They just stay on the top the water we collected at the bottom is
Definitely different than the water on the top now the one in the middle
I'm a little bit surprised about because we actually had two different layers of Charcoal
And I would have expected that to be the clearest out of all of them now what I think happened is when I was building
this one
I actually ran out of my really fine charcoal, and I just started putting the chunky charcoal instead
so
obviously
It didn't filter the water quite as good as the really fine charcoal does this shows the finer your charcoal the clearer your water is
Actually going to be let's take a look down inside and check it for clarity
So I've just transferred our two large samples to two glasses.
We can look inside and check for clarity and you see the one on the left has slightly yellow tinge to it the one on
The right that looks absolutely fantastic and if you look down here
You look straight through the glass you can't see any particulate floating around whatsoever
This water right here looks beautiful looks refreshing. It looks crystal clear
It looks delicious in a survival situation, it's going to be the nectar of life however
There's one thing left to do before you drink it and that's to sterilize it
Alright guys. I am back with my sterilized water. I just stuck this in the microwave for 4 minutes however
There are a lot of alternative methods you could use for purifying water as well such as water purification tablets, UV stir sticks
And I've even heard of people sticking water in clear plastic bottles and setting them out in sunlight for 24 to 48 hours
But for simplicity on this project I went ahead and use the boiling water method
That's the method that's most commonly used and after you boil water for a couple of minutes
It's pretty much enough to kill anything in the water that could hurt you so they say so here. We are guys
This is the moment of truth. We've got our green scummy pond water that we have transformed into
sterilized charcoaled filtered water
It's filtered sanitized life-giving zero-Calorie sugar-free gluten-free dairy-free and ready to drink so this is it
I'm actually so confident. This is sterilized and ready to drink. I'm just going to down the whole thing here we go
Bangarang. That was actually really good that tastes
Probably a lot different than this taste. I mean look mosquito Larvae are still having a heyday in there
So in a survival situation I choose our charcoal filter water which is made out of materials from the backyard Dirt, sand
Charcoal and look how crystal-clear that comes out this is a viable option guys
This is how you survive because water is one of the essentials
So there you have a guys that's one cool trick to taking ugly disgusting contaminated water and turning it into sanitized, purified
Totally drinkable water it might just save your life now
You guys know I post videos every single day
So if you're really curious to know whether or not this was actually safe for me to drink
click subscribe ring the bell to receive my future post notifications because if I stop posting
Well, you'll know what happened
Thanks for joining me for this project today if an emergency pops up I hope this might help save your life
I'll see you in the next video talk to you then
I love charcoal.
Just went into my lungs. Oh oh, oh
There they go spill it all over the place. You're not having a mess you're not making fun
Hey guys quick reminder
there's a link in the description right now to download The Walking Dead no man's land for free if you download before the end of
July you'll unlock the character, Negan go get em Boys!